Peter how do you know when it's time to
quit your business and start something
else would quitting be a sign of defeat
people used to say we want to go and
probably used to fail and the kind of
that tremendous tenacity and
perseverance to overcome adversity yeah
i think you know reality is if it's a in
the end you gotta work it's a dumb idea
there's no value for the customers or
the market then it's really important to
say actually stop that idea but the
experiences of games will pound me into
a different idea of where my passion is
I'm actually an angel investor in two
businesses where they have brilliant
ideas for the market just changed
against him and they actually are
fantastic you know startup management
team loads of innovation in the business
but the market just wasn't there but
having said that the third time that
then she went and became successful
refocus in their ideas on a new market
they were passionate about they've had
success so I kind of think there's two
things one is kind of pursue when you
determine you're going to quit the best
way to validate that is unless socially
or directly to consumers talk to the
customers to try to set if they say it's
a crazy idea and there's nobody or it
might be too early to the market loads
of ideas are too early for the market
and then all ready for prime time um
then kind of pause due course correction
determine where you can move get back to
your passion and come up with an idea
it's going to work I guess my curve
balance would be up in your business
then it's time to move on and that may
not be quitting the business I could be
selling the business to this loads of
entrepreneurs who build it up their
company to a certain size and then they
get bored and then they start looking
for other things to do whether it's
invest in a new companies to start if
you know when that happens your current
business just kind of stagnates because
you're not pulling the love energy
passionate you were pouring in before
and so the answer for me is if you lose
the
fire it's time to move on if it's at the
point where you can sell it to somebody
else great do that and make do something
that makes you come alive again and it's
at the point where it's not something
that anybody would want to take on
because it's to embryonic and the market
wasn't there you couldn't get customers
then close it down and go do something
else and there's there's lots of
failures that you'll have along the path
failure isn't the enemy the enemy is
keeping on doing something because you
feel you should but you don't have
passion for it you're never going to be
able to build anything great if you
don't have that energy and excitement
that week separately morally go and pour
into your company